eating gold is like the equivalent of
wiping your butt with dollar bills at
some point it's just gonna come in
contact with my ass this is doing it in
a kind of more elegant way right so
we're in New York right now we're still
you have to get an ice cream this
morning I need to stop having dessert
for breakfast yeah it's kind of a
problem but that's okay we're gonna fill
this little belly up with pizza so today
and tomorrow we were gonna be trying
three drastically different New York
Pizza places that very drastically
different price point to find out which
one's the most worth it at ass given
price point actually we do have a
special guest who might be one of the
best people poor shadowy
before our previous with an episode
together on pizza I get the works but I
learn that pizza is really about the
crust you look like a the works kind of
guy you are on the Jersey Shore your
nickname would be the works your hair
it's got the works my jackets got the
works you give people the work so
clarify that for my girlfriend I cannot
give anybody the works first husband go
into it's a nice little shop in the
village called Joe's pizza I love pizza
it's the best food in the best place
with the best people
my name is Alexson we are here at Joe's
pizza and the greatest village I've been
working here for more than 25 years Wow
but the places we've been here since
1975 who never change your recipe you
guys are the best right yeah whoever
wants to buy a knife well done few times
they come here we know some tools they
come like 20 years ago and they still
come around them and their families and
difference
the lady
every day she walk from midtown to here
by two slices go home three years like
the beginning of the pizza is in the
kitchen because I make the dog go flour
to make it easy to work and then I
stretch it cartoon special even not too
big not too small gotta be gentle right
I'm not gentle all right I'm hard with
the dog this dough is okay but it's too
cold oh it's too cold it's gonna have to
stretch it all depends of the weather
summertime rice you need an hour and a
half every pizza is different I could
make thousands of pie is gonna be
thousands kind of different and then the
sauce is only one scoop what's good to
put more generally to something I have
to be careful with the amount of salt
got to be spread and nice and even I
grab the cheese and I pull it and I see
it always just try to put the same spot
so many years already how's gonna come
out the oven itself has to do with a
favor there's a 40 years old man working
every night you never shut it off honey
nella Peter's minutes making the whale
active is golden in the valley and
around and the cheese he eats every day
more every day at least once a week say
once a week no ya lookin some of that
everlasting immortal pizza we've done a
lot of awesome food before yeah this is
probably the most excited I've ever been
it only is piece of my favorite food but
this is my favorite incarnation
this slice no dream right now no what
then got that crunch so you either sorry
I could crush like ten days right it has
a satisfying true but it still makes a
sound in every part of it that you bite
into you get that crunch if not a pile
of grease no greaseless it's actually
kind of like pizza there's just enough
burnt bits where you have a slight
bitter taste and then the sweet sauce
cancels that out perfect know what you
hope every piece of pizza is gonna taste
like good
this is unquestionably New York style
pizza you don't even have to be hungry
to watch those pizzas
it's a treat pizza I think I'm gonna
have this pizza for dessert after every
next pizza place we got you what do you
think about that I think I want more
pizza you want to hook us up to more
this is the kind of pizza you would eat
alone that's when you know the food's
good we've come for the food not for the
company tell me about it Adam beat the
back can't get better than this no I
think it gets different than this it
just like what's an analogy you know
this is perfect what did you think of
Joe's pizza it's just the the cartoon
it's what the Ninja Turtles would eat it
didn't look perfect before he made it
turning imperfect a perfect very hard to
judge he could sense differences in the
pizza that I don't think I could ever
since it's raining outside so the dough
is a little more humid the moon is full
so it rises a little higher it's just
like the sunset yes one's a little
different but it still makes the world
go round
think we can get the whole train to say
Pete's effect at the same time
I'm not gonna yell because we're in a
public space he's the best there is a 3d
printer that prints pizza NASA wanted to
print pizzas for astronauts in space we
already have a 3d pizza printer his name
is Alex at Joe's are you ready for this
next place I'm scared we're about to eat
a pizza made by the mario batali the
Italian in season 1 we actually ate at a
restaurant that Marty the vitaly helped
start and now we're gonna make lunch for
us yeah I'm here
hey fellas my name is Mario Batali I
wear short pants for a living and I'm
making pizza we are at easily Flatiron
and this is a restaurant called Rosso
Pomodoro Italy is an experiential
grocery store our messages you shouldn't
go out to dinner fundamentally the store
is about buying stuff here and making it
yourself can you buy everything here you
need to make this piece of everything
that you eat you can buy in this store
and we will give you the recipe this is
Neapolitan pizza the fundamental story
behind both pizza and pasta is that the
noodle or the crust is the dish
everything else that's on it is merely a
condiment you would never get a works
pizza in Italy so you make the dough
this is a dough that is quite delicate
so it's not one that you throw the idea
is to stretch it consistently so that
it's nice and pin about this big around
then we dress it with just a little bit
of tomato sauce which is crushed San
marzanos that's it a little bit of herbs
a little oregano a little extra virgin
olive oil into the oven that's it when
it gets a little brown on the left side
where the heat source is you just give
it a little spin comes out you sprinkle
with a couple more oregano leaves that's
the pie I made a calzone in case you got
hungry oh it's pretty good we're gonna
eat you sit down and eat I would love to
you can we do that yep yeah Mady not a
pizza there's no cheese good no this is
where you truly understand the
magnificence of the bread being the
story the sauce being the condiment and
go ahead try yeah cheers cheers Cheers
I'm gonna say you ate it from the back I
always want to check to make sure the
crust is in the right spot and it is
yeah so my mouth that's the way it
survived the crust is just my favorite
part that's what I want
it's just that dough I can't believe
this is just fresh tomatoes why am i
eating tomatoes with anything else in it
that's a question I often ask to other
people I know that people are gonna look
at this pizza and say it's burnt what
are you thinking about that it's gonna
say that some guy on the Internet is
gonna say that we're gonna look at that
and say this word but isn't that
important in this course or the burnt
piece we're not hiding this there was a
char to our bass but when you eat that
that bitterness
is measured out against the song of the
tomato sauce right like that better
makes sense doesn't it when I met Korean
BBQ and you got those burnt pieces still
left on the grill
that's my jam right the Italian bite
needs to have a whimsy and Caprice to it
because they like one by to be rude I'm
one don't beat now try this calzone it's
classically filled only with ricotta and
prosciutto pork block which is the cook
ham not for shoot law department oh dear
God it's succulent the way that a jelly
filled donut is well said it's like if I
took a bite of a pig that was still
moving and it had submitted to your
carnal desires yeah that's what it
should taste like I feel weird saying
that but that's what I said it there's
good pizza in this town you know Joe's
like the best slice in New York
yes Joe's on father Deimos Square yeah
we were there last night that is a New
York slice there was almost nothing
better neither should be excluded from
the party someone's got to do a
investigation to what goes into these
cans of tomatoes why don't we take your
show on the road I'll take you to Naples
I would do that there's a rich sweetness
to almost everything that grows there is
due to that volcanic kind of soil that
they have there's something poetic about
tomatoes grown in the soil where a
volcano erupted yeah being sweeter to
compliment the char enos sorriness on a
piece of reading today
[Music]
I think we both just got put to shame
I'm just a little thirsty you know what
I work all day long
this style of Pizza what was its purpose
not necessarily a meal it was probably
even considered maybe a side dish or
just the bread tomato sauce came from
the new world so 1600s would have been
the first time you saw a real beat so
pizza sauce comes from the new world
tomatoes were from America not from
Italy yeah be kidding me no you just
love food I love everything about it the
story the practice the production when I
became a cook in 1978 anybody could peel
potatoes for soup in the ensuing 30 to
40 years who transcended merely fuel and
meals you guys are eating thousand
dollar case the world has changed well
this way is one of the best experiences
for us thank you very much grab me
there's the allegedly burnt piece for
the angry guy on the internet there's a
charm
oh okay Adam Adam just committed to a
big fight you're gonna have to give him
a second here so we just in Italy at
their pizzeria which i think is called
comodoro of also means red tomato
look at me I'm practically a Batali a
Batali or Italian I'm a battalion whoa I
can't believe how good that boots it
tasted he made cooking look so simple
and so easy I'm ready for a no cheese
pizza fact pizza fat Naples actually had
the world record for the longest pizza
ever longest yes yes how long it was is
it still a circle give me a number 20
feet did I nail it 6,000 feet haha
that's over a mile they cook it over a
volcano volcanoes not even that big
we're going to the final pizza you ready
for this pizza mm big ones 6,000 foot
pizza $2,000 pizza this is
all job right no we're gonna eat if he
doesn't like pizza do we have the money
for that
[Music]
my name is Laurie Boone I am executive
chef of English a kitchen today we wanna
eat this at $2,000 fix does it have a
name
24k 24k pizza yeah come on idea because
when I walk down Broadway you see the
big jewelry store this is a Broadway
jewelry store at a place yes so you just
wanted to find the best ingredient
regardless of the cops exactly a
fee-only is to be different than
everyone in your city I want to do it
when I stretch the pizza dough the dough
the squid ink then we want to put the
foie gras sink and cheese for England
today I want to put winter black chosen
from friends in the 24k gold from
Ecuador industries also sprinkles then
bake in the oven seven to ten minutes
then go outside with Osetra caviar from
Caspian Sea do you think you're ever
gonna make a pizza that's better than
this one I don't think so haha diamonds
not next you cannot eat them you cannot
eat I've it watch me try I got a strong
stomach I know I don't you can die say
it as it is it's kind of crazy it's the
gold pizza we need a couple hundred
dollars worth of gold let's see if it
works a Mac so we got here the 24k it's
the gold season let's do this thing
look at you learning
it was the thing I do with real people I
eat with - I might not have real friends
family we're not there yet I feel like
we're family more than friends you know
I'm not sure if it's our purpose to be
there as some rich as I felt watching a
pet gold shade go just like feel like
that would be your stripper alter ego
gold shaker
the richest you'll ever feel has a lot
of fun it's like the slice
I want this one oh look at that crossing
Oh
whoa look at $30 bite right there I
wasn't like super confident I knew what
Stilton tasted like it's actually really
creamy and smooth and is a nice kind of
backdrop for the caviar and the foie
gras at the end of the day it's still
pizza right you eat it
[Applause]
mm honestly speechless you never get
used to eating gold oh man I can't waste
the book on Goldfinger we've had foie
gras now we've had the caviar taco now
she's all coming together it's one way
to think of it yeah gold I love ya this
is a pizza you got to share though I
feel weird
is it the gold I just ate two hundred
and fifty dollars this pizza I would one
slice in my mouth too fitting what this
pizzas doing for me is it's a filling
one of my greatest fantasies always been
a huge fan of James Bond as I grew up I
realized I am a little bit more of a
Bond villain and eating this pizza I
feel like a Bond villain I want to eat
this in my volcano lair
James Bond is locked up he probably
escaped already because I never do it
right you are right that I feel I feel
kind of like like I'm committing a crime
I think that's the greatest gift you've
ever given me can we be building
together you'd be more like my henchman
it's fine with me here's what I think we
should do bring it back to us via New
York headquarters sharing the wealth how
many times in your life have you gotten
a slice of pizza that you didn't know
you're gonna get have a slice I'm not
gonna eat it all anyway it's kind of
like this beard of Pizza let's go back
us up from some more people oh man whoa
and that's what
$1,250 looks like in a cardboard box
[Music]
no I don't like this has been possibly
my favorite episode so far the
Neapolitan from Italy which is the
perfect representation of what Pizza
originally was and you have Jose which
is the perfect American slice what was
the most worth it for me probably the
Jose slice what it was the most pizza
that Pizza has ever been so in the
freaking a pretty industry kitchen pizza
two thousand dollars all the ingredients
together I think I would prefer
personally to eat them individually
Mario Batali's pizza a meal is best
enjoyed with friends and we got a new
friend today my worth a winner both
Italy I struggle to digest cheese oh
you're just like toasted I obviously
picked the one that's not gonna make you
far he inspired me to change my life is
our cooking board really yeah Mario sent
him a book and he's a lot of help Adam
who's your worth it winner you know what
I really want though dessert pizza -
Jose
if I was blindfolded and had a cheese
slice in this slice so you'd know milk
is your first primary response your
lactic sensors would fire like a baby
sucking on the teeth oh yes